detroit famed for its riches to rags to
riches story is reeling our emergency
rooms have been packed we are literally
running out of inpatient capacity the
corona virus threatens to undermine the
Motor City's rapid recovery from a 2013
bankruptcy Detroit's TCF center was
scheduled to house a North American
International Auto Show in June that was
expected to bring in four hundred
million dollars now instead beginning
Thursday it will begin accepting
patients to the thousand bed emergency
coronavirus hospital
this facility is specifically for Kovan
patients they are going to create
negative pressure in here just like on
the hospital room so the patients can
use oxygen if needed but they will be
quarantined other patients the Motor
City is just the latest virus hotspot to
make the demoralizing conversion from
commercial halt to crisis medical center
it's a model the US Army Corps of
Engineers has pursued in coronavirus hot
spots around the u.s. from New York's
massive Jacob K Javits Convention Center
to Illinois largest city where engineers
have been installing thousands of beds
in a matter of days Chicago's McCormick
Place is North America's largest
convention center but the conventions
are all closed in Illinois under a
statewide lockdown order so this
sprawling complex is now a three
thousand bed hospital devoted entirely
to coronavirus throughout neighboring
Michigan the virus is moving fast
our numbers are climbing exponentially
we knew it was a matter of time not if
kovat 19 would come to michigan we took
aggressive measures we've been on the
front end of aggressive measures that
states have been taking but we see this
astronomical rise seven years after the
bankruptcy that brought Motown's engine
back to life
the virus threatens to bring that
progress to a grinding halt
john hendren al jazeera Chicago